aux journées sur et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france on va
commencer avec vous maxime thiébaut on a
donc une mobilisation qui continue 8e
samedi consécutif est ce qu'on peut
parler d'un week-end décisif pour la
suite du mouvement
bien sûr c'est le week-end de rentrée
donc c'est forcément le week-end qu'il
ne fallait pas rater après j'ai pas
encore les chiffres officiels du
ministère de l'intérieur même si je me
méfie toujours de ces derniers mais en
tout cas j'ai quand même constaté qu'il
y avait énormément de monde aussi bien
la manifestation de florian philippot
que dans les divers autres
manifestations des gilets jaunes et
partout en france à aix en provence
énormément de monde chalon sur saône
montceau les mines fin tout un tas de
petites villes partout en france il y
avait un petit peu de monde donc on sent
qu'il y a une motivation à se mobiliser
contre le pass sanitaires alors que la
rentrée est en cours
antonin teisseire vous constatez vous
aussi à une motiver une motivation
pardon qui ne faiblit pas
oui absolument sur un sujet aussi
fondamental c'est même une chance de se
rendre compte que les français peuvent
transcender les barrières politiques
pour se retrouver autour d'un sujet
aussi fondamental
soulever la question de du caractère
potentiellement moi je n'irai pas jusque
là mais potentiellement le début je te
quelque chose qui pourrait vouloir
ressembler une tyrannie mais la question
comme l'a dit la dernière personne
interviewée dans le cortège et bien sûr
l'avenir à quoi va-t-on s'habituer et de
quoi va-t-on devoir justifier pour faire
valoir nos droits et nos libertés dans
un avenir proche
maxime thibeault le gouvernement n'a pas
atteint son objectif des 50 millions de
vaccinés ans et a attendu pour la fin du
mois d'août le discours clivants du
président de la république at il a
braqué une partie des français selon
vous
il a premièrement braquer une partie des
français parce que manuel macro engrand
jupitérien le 12 juillet avait décidé de
diviser les français en deux entre les
non vaccinés et les vaccinés on se rend
compte aussi que la vaccination ne fait
que lui et par deux la transmission du
virus et du colis de 19 et donc en
réalité elle n'est pas efficace pour les
personnes les plus jeunes et les
personnes qui ne souffrent pas comment
me dit est en fait la vaccination elle
est intéressante pour éviter les formes
graves de la maladie et donc on doit la
recommander ou personnes âgées aux
personnes qui souffrent de comorbidité
comme l'asthme le diabète le cancer etc
mais on aurait pu en rester là on aurait
pu en rester sur la recommandation en
étant dans un pays libéral est un pays
qui respecte les libertés fondamentales
en disant bah voilà ceux qui ont besoin
de se faire vacciner faites vous
vacciner et la vie reprend normalement
parce que le taux de mortalité reste
très bas emmanuel macron a préféré
vacciner l'ensemble de la population une
mesure où demeurant totalement
disproportionnée et je rappelle que le
conseil d'état comme le conseil
constitutionnel ne se sont pas prononcés
sur la question ils ont évacué la
question considérant par ailleurs que le
bassin sanitaire n'était pas assez
d'actes sinan donc oui emmanuel macron
est aujourd'hui en train d'échouer et
juillet sur une communication qui était
mauvaise parce que il aurait pu parler à
l'intelligence des français et il a
préféré les menacer et s'avère in fine
et que la vaccination ne permet pas
d'endiguer le taux d'incidence je veux
par exemple le cas d'israël en tenant un
pêcheur vous êtes d'accord avec ça
emmanuel macron a échoué dans sa
communication à sa stratégie vaccinale
tout dépend l'objectif que emmanuel
macron poursuit il est le seul à
connaître son son but dans cette
histoire je reçois absolument tout ce
que monsieur diallo dr thiébaut a pu
évoquer la l'instant j'irai même plus
loin en disant que non seulement c'est
une mesure inefficace qui n'a rien de
sanitaires métier à toute politique et
surtout qui est criminel et criminel
parce que quand vous avez et centaine le
décès liés à des vaccins en phase
expérimentale
je pense que il est 2e et lille et ce
serait une bonne idée de mettre fin en
fait à cette expérimentation rappelons
que l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
est toujours provisoire pour ces
substances
et à ce titre là
question de savoir si on est pour le
vaccin en compte leurs vaccins n'a aucun
sens pour moi la question est de savoir
si le gouvernement cherche d'autres
solutions qui seraient efficaces plutôt
que de se concentrer le cristallisé le
débat sur cette question alors à corps
on sait très bien on le voit ce vaccin
ne fonctionnera pas pour endiguer la
pandémie maxime thibeault on constate ou
en tout cas aux dernières nouvelles que
de toute façon le gouvernement ne
cherche pas comme l'évoquent antonin
peschard de une autre une autre
alternative au vaccin
c'était l'alpha et l'oméga la
vaccination vous voyez les pub à la
télévision la vaccination c'est freedom
c'est la liberté mais on voit très bien
une fine et que ce n'est pas le cas à
partir du moment où le gouvernement a
indexé la libération du pays sur la
baisse du taux d'incidence bien en ait
tronqué parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on
ne luttera pas contre la transmission du
vaccin sauf à fermer le pays s'était
complètement aberrant face à une maladie
qui est un taux de mortalité aussi bas
ce qui aurait fallu faire c'est comme
les pays comme la suède et d'autres pays
occidentaux c'est faire preuve
d'intelligence on a un outil intéressant
quel vaccin mettons le à disposition de
ceux qui ont donc besoin personnes
vulnérables personnes âgées et luttons
contre la maladie avec d'autres systèmes
ya les traitements personnellement je
connais pas suffisamment la question
pour me prononcer mais on sait que ces
maladies qui attaquent les comorbidités
notamment les personnes obèses et en
même temps on a voulu fermer les gens et
entretenir les comorbidités est il
n'aurait pas été plus intéressant de
développer une politique sur le long
terme en investissement en investissant
réellement dans l'hôpital public alors
qu'on a fermé à peu près mille huit
cents lits depuis 18 mois en
investissant dans le sport en
investissant dans tout un tas de
questions de la santé publique et qui
aurait permis en fait aussi d'éviter les
conséquences de tout ce qu'on connaît en
termes de confinement et en terme de
pression psychologique du gouvernement
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on a des
dépressions en masse qu'on a des gens
qui ont décroché dans leur activité
professionnelle des élèves qui ont
décroché dans l'activité scolaire et que
les conséquences sanitaires seront bien
pires les conséquences parlons des
mesures politiques du gouvernement
seront bien pires que le comique 19 on
constate malgré deux fous antonin
peschard que 67% des français
soutiennent le pass and i ter selon un
sondage ou doxa la bataille est elle
définitivement perdu pour les anti-pacs
sanitaires
absolument pas je pense que j'espère moi
qui ai un grand optimiste qu'elle est en
passe d'être remporté par ces personnes
par cette minorité qui aujourd'hui vient
crier dans la rue son mécontentement au
four se pencher sur l'histoire pour
compte du recul dans ce genre de
situation on se trouve avec des seconds
se retrouve avec des oeillères en voyant
qu'une seule chose qu'un seul débat plus
simplement peut-être de 2 et les deux
événements historiques les français
étaient favorables à la peine de mort
lorsque son abolition a été votée je
crois que ça c'est un fait historique
que tout le monde connaît et sur lequel
on peut se rapporter souvent les
résistants aussi alors loin de moi
l'idée de faire une quelconque parallèle
qui
pas politiser les gouvernements et la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais du point
de vue de la résistance rappelons que
les français étaient minoritaires
maxime s'il repart devant ses 67 % de
français qui soutiennent le pass annie
terre ça vous évoque quoi mais moi ça
m'évoque un chiffre qui a troqué par
nature pourquoi parce que les gens sont
vaccinés et une partie des français se
disent bas étant donné je suis vacciné
je vois pas pourquoi je propose au pass
sanitaire dans la mesure je présente un
qr code mais vous allez voir si on
commence à dire aux gens faut faire une
troisième dose ou bien si on commence à
leur expliquer que finalement va
remettre des mesures un peu plus
contraignantes vous avez que le
changement va avoir lieu voilà je
regrette un petit peu parfois je suis un
peu un peu gêné avec eux avec les
français en général c'est qu'il n'ait
pas compris que derrière le pass adf
s'installe une société de contrôle qui
va durer longtemps qu'ils vont
s'habituer en fait à cette mesure de
contrôle social et que le pass annie
terme n'est pas près d'en sortir et que
sur d'autres maladies peut-être il sera
installé c'est vous savez la politique
de contrôle qui a été développé par
foucault et c'est ça c'est la petite
gêne on sait mais vous savez qu'on va
parler de la troisième et qu'on va
commencer à dire en français finalement
la vaccination c'était pas la garantie
pense qu'on va voir beaucoup plus
d'opposition et le gouvernement n'avait
pas du tout prévu ce changement
conjoncturel qui est la vaccination ne
sonne pas aussi bien et que l'opposition
passe à lille est toujours aussi fort
merci beaucoup maxime qui bouge rappelle
que vous êtes docteur en droit public y
est merci à vous antonin peschard avocat
au barreau de paris